tach zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu
zdf arte live euren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und es ist ja mittlerweile schon fast
ein ritual in diesen anderthalb jahren
die bund länder konferenz das treffen
der ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
und der bundesregierung die sich in
schönster regelmäßigkeit zusammensetzen
um zu beraten wie die korona regeln für
die nächste zeit aussehen sollen und wie
immer herrschte auch bei diesen treffen
heute vorher allerschönste uneinigkeit
klar ist nur dass es weiterhin regeln
geben soll anders als in ländern wie den
vereinigten königreich dem united
kingdom in england ist jetzt zum
beispiel die masken pflicht zum größten
zeit aufgehoben da gilt eine
selbstverantwortung der bürger wie das
boris johnson der premierminister sagte
bei uns soll das aber nicht so kommen
denn wir haben zwar mittlerweile 54
prozent der menschen in deutschland voll
durch geimpft aber das reicht eben nicht
um die so genannte herdenimmunität zu
erreichen um gut durch den herbst und
winter zu kommen und die inzidenz steigt
dann dank data variante immer weiter an
wir sind gerade bei 23,5 bundesweit also
23,5 corona fälle auf 100000 einwohner
bundesweit es ist noch relativ weit
unten wenn wir mal überlegen ließen
dezember ausgesehen hat aber es ist
höher als im letzten juli als die zahl
sehr viel niedriger ausland können uns
nicht noch mal angucken in einem
dashboard vom robert-koch-institut ja
und wenn das so weitergeht befürchten
halt die politiker innen vor allem der
bundesgesundheitsminister dass die
zahlen im herbst richtig übel aussehen
richtig nach oben gehen und das ist die
frage was macht man jetzt
es wurde viel diskutiert im vorhinein
und darüber sprechen wir jetzt unter
anderem mit meiner kollegin nicole
diekmann wir warten auf die
pressekonferenz aber nicole ist schon
mal da und kann uns vielleicht schon mal
etwas erzählen wie ist die letzten
stunden abgegangen ist in berlin was es
dazu der durchgedrungen ist tatsächlich
eine einigung erzielt worden
also sagen wir mal
es ist jetzt die 29 mpk erfahren wir zu
diesem thema corona das ja heute das
hauptthema gewesen ist und da haben wir
schon längere sitzungen erlebt zum
beispiel auch du und ich in unseren
funktionen die wir heute haben das heißt
es wurde schon diskutiert es gab wohl
auch knackpunkte
aber es hätte auch durchaus länger gehen
können
du hast es ja gerade schon gesagt wir
sehen es ja auch im kroll es gibt einen
beschluss ab dem 11 oktober das ist ein
montag ist schluss mit den kostenlose
sogenannten bürger tests für alle ab da
müssen diejenigen die hätten geimpft
werden können es aber nicht gewollt
haben dafür bezahlen das ist schon mal
eine große einigung die man aber auch
ein bisschen absehen konnte da gab es
parteiübergreifend von vielen
ministerpräsidentinnen in den
vergangenen tagen schon zustimmung das
zu beschließen
das ist mit der frage für das geimpfte
dürfen oder was sie nicht dürfen das war
ja ein ganz großes streitthema gibt es
jetzt ja keine einschränkungen mehr für
die menschen mit den 3g also getestet
genießen oder geimpft gibt es da
irgendwie schon was was durchgesickert
ist
da kann man sehr gespannt sein denn das
war tatsächlich einer der knackpunkte
heute vor allem eben die frage behandelt
man diese drei gruppen geimpfte genesene
getestete gleich oder aber schränkt man
die rechte derer die lediglich getestet
sind die nicht geimpft sind weiter ein
was klar ist ist auch wir geimpften
werden weiterhin im bus und bahn beim
einkaufen maske tragen müssen es gab
eine beschlussvorlage aus dem kanzleramt
die vorsieht das getestete nicht
geimpfte tatsächlich tests vorliegen
müssen wollen sie zum beispiel in die
ebenen gastronomie
da können wir erst mal gleich gucken was
da tatsächlich kommt du guckst rüber wir
gucken da rüber
denn in diesem augenblick beginnt die
pressekonferenz von bund und ländern und
einem merkel die bundeskanzlerin
eröffnet wie er mit der bundeskanzlerin
es heißt also mit der bundesregierung
getroffen und hatten zwei
tagesordnungspunkte sehr
unterschiedliche art aber bei
außerordentlich wichtig das erste war
die bewältigung der
hochwasserkatastrophe und ihrer folgen
wir können sagen dass deutschland und
hier insbesondere die bundesländer
rheinland pfalz und nordrhein westfalen
in einer bisher nicht gekannten art und
weise von den folgen eines hochwassers
erfasst wurden und wir haben natürlich
noch einmal unser mitgefühl ausgedrückt
mit den angehörigen der opfer und auch
den opfern die verletzungen und
materielle schäden haben wir sind
unendlich dankbar
das ist heute auch durch die beiden
ministerpräsidenten armin laschet und
mahlow drei jahren noch einmal deutlich
geworden dass eine so umfassende
hilfsbereitschaft aus dem ehrenamtlichen
und privaten bereich stattgefunden hat
das sehr sehr viele freiwillige helfer
auch heute noch tätig sind aber wir
wissen dass das natürlich eine aufgabe
ist die von gesamtstaatlicher bedeutung
ist und ich bin sehr froh dass wir neben
den bereits am 21 juli beschlossenen
soforthilfen auch heute hilfen
vereinbaren konnten die langfristiger
natur sind es ist inzwischen eine
schadensermittlung erfolgt durch die
besonders betroffenen bundesländer und
die sagt uns dass wir ein sondervermögen
des bundes mit 30 milliarden euro
aufbauen müssen das ist deutlich mehr
als wir das bei dem letzten hochwasser
hatten und die wiederaufbaumaßnahmen der
länder in höhe von 28 milliarden 2
milliarden sind schäden an bundes
infrastruktur werden je zur hälfte von
bund und ländern finanziert das ist ein
zeichen gesamtstaatlicher solidarität
und wegen der sehr hohen summe wird
diesmal die beteiligung der länder
gesamtheit eine bei einer anpassung der
sogenannten vertikalen verteilung des
umsatzsteuer aufkommens über 30 jahre
erfolgen das bundeskabinett wird diese
hilfen am 18 august beschließen und der
deutsche bundestag wird wahrscheinlich
dass es die sache des bundestages waren
in der woche drauf die erste lesung
dieses gesetzentwurfes vornehmen so dass
wir dann in der sitzung des deutschen
bundestages im september die zweite und
dritte lesung durchführen können und
sehr zeitnah damit auch klarheit für die
verantwortliche für die betroffenen da
sein wird wir werden auch weitere
hilfsmaßnahmen und vor allen dingen
einen sehr engen kontakt zu den aufbau
stäben der betroffenen bundesländer mit
haben und wir haben in der
bundesregierung den
staatssekretärsausschuss der versucht
alle hilfen unbürokratisch auch
durchzuführen die planungsrechtlichen
dinge zu klären die natürlich im
wesentlichen in länderhoheit liegen aber
vor allen dingen hier wirklich schnell
auch zu handeln und wir bitten auch die
justizministerkonferenz noch einmal vor
dem hintergrund der aktuellen ereignisse
zu prüfen ob die bisherige bewertung der
pflichtversicherung das ja alles schon
mal geprüft worden weiter bestand haben
soll oder ob wir sie doch aktualisieren
müssen
ich habe mich gefreut dass dieser teil
der beratung wirklich sehr zügig ging
und dass da eine große große gemeinsame
bereitschaft ist in dieser
außergewöhnlichen situation den menschen
die betroffen sind von den verwüstungen
muss man ja sagen zu helfen
zweitens ging es um maßnahmen zur
bewältigung der korona pandemie wir sind
jetzt in einer völlig anderen situation
als wir das sehr oft bei diesen
pressekonferenzen hier waren jetzt haben
wir genug impfstoff und wir müssen dafür
werben dass geimpft wird wir sind im
europäischen vergleich nicht mehr spitze
sondern es gibt eine reihe von ländern
die besser und in freudiger sind als
deutschland
und wir haben heute am heutigen tage
55,1 prozent der bevölkerung vollständig
geimpft und 62,5 prozent
mal wir haben eine ziemliche spanne auch
zwischen den bundesländern aber die
durchschnittswerte habe ich gesagt
erfreulich ist dass im durchschnitt über
80 prozent der über 60-jährigen die ja
im wesentlichen unter den folgen dieser
corona pandemie sehr viel stärker zu
leiden haben als jüngere geimpft sind
das ist schon ein erheblicher schutz und
wir können davon ausgehen dass auch und
das ist die gute nachricht bei der delta
mutation die impf wirkung sehr sehr
positiv ist insbesondere bezüglich
schwerer verläufe der partie die nicht
so gute nachricht ist dass das impf
tempo doch erheblich nachgelassen hat
und deshalb sind wir uns einig dass
jeder in seiner verantwortung bund und
länder aber auch kommunale
verantwortliche wo immer es geht für das
impfen werben wir wissen dass die
angebote sehr niederschwellig sein
müssen dass man zu den menschen gehen
muss und ich bitte auch von dieser
stelle heute noch einmal alle freunde
bekannten familienmitglieder die
vielleicht schon geimpft sind in ihren
freundeskreisen und familienkreisen
sportvereins kreisen dafür zu werben
dass andere sich auch impfen lassen weil
es einfach ein schutz für uns alle ist
nicht nur für den einzelnen sondern auch
für uns alle also wir tun etwas für uns
wäre der jeder für sich aber wir tun
eben auch etwas für diejenigen die nicht
geimpft werden können seien es kindern
noch gar kein im angebot haben seien es
menschen die so vor erkrankt sind dass
sie nicht geimpft werden können
und insofern ist es also auch ein
beitrag für die gemeinschaft den jeder
einzelne leisten kann
wir haben trotzdem fortschritte eine
steigerung desinfektions geschehens und
natürlich hängt die zahl der infizierten
sehr stark von der impfquote ab das
heißt wir werden weniger infektionen
haben wenn wir mehr geimpfte haben und
wir waren uns auch darüber einig dass
wir zur beurteilung des gesamt
geschehens auch andere indikatoren
brauchen ich will allerdings
ausdrücklich sagen
die inzidenz das heißt die zahl der
fälle pro 1000 einwohner korreliert
jetzt anders ist also anders verbunden
mit zum beispiel der zahl der
krankenhausaufenthalte durch die zu hohe
zahl der geimpften also im grunde wenn
man davon ausgeht dass die jüngsten
keinen schweren verlauf mehr haben zählt
immer die bevölkerungs menge die noch
gemeinschaft die noch nicht geimpft ist
aber die durchläuft die pandemie
natürlich genauso wie zu der zeit als
alle noch nicht geimpft waren
das heißt ein fünftel der über 80
jährigen die heute noch nicht geimpft
sind muss mit den gleichen folgen
rechnen aber es sind natürlich in der
gesamtheit sehr viel weniger menschen
und das hat natürlich eine positive
wirkung auf unser gesundheitssystem
wir wollen alle dass wir
niedrigschwellige mit niedrigschwelligen
maßnahmen die den anstieg der
infektionszahlen eindämmen können und
weil aber die pandemie weiter da ist
weil die delta variante auch sehr
aggressiv ist und sehr ansteckend ist
also nicht von der wirkung der
erkrankung schwieriger aber von der
schnelligkeit der ansteckung brauchen
wir basis schutzmaßnahmen für die
gesamte bevölkerung besonders in einer
zeit wo eben gerade mal 55,1 prozent
vollständig geimpft sind und dazu
bekennen wir uns das heißt also die asl
regeln sind weiter einzuhalten
schutzmasken medizinischer art im
einzelhandel im öffentlichen
personenverkehr bleiben für die
bevölkerung verbindlich vorgeschrieben
und wir werden natürlich wie alle
anderen maßnahmen diese auch alle vier
wochen zu sorglosen wir wollen dann zur
weiteren vermeidung des anstiegs die
sogenannte 3g regel durchsetzen und zwar
geimpft genesen oder getestete personen
bei veranstaltungen in innenräumen weil
wir wissen dass hier das
infektionsgeschehen von besonderer
bedeutung ist das gilt für den zugang zu
krankenhäusern alten- und pflegeheimen
und einrichtungen der behindertenhilfe
zu rinnen gastronomie zur teilnahme an
veranstaltungen und festen informations
kultur und sportveranstaltungen in
innenräumen für die inanspruchnahme
körper dar dienstleistungen sport im
innenbereich und beherbergung test bei
anreise und zweimal pro woche während
des aufenthalts die länder können
regelung vorsetzt vorsehen dass die
dreijährige ganz oder teilweise
ausgesetzt ist solange die sieben tage
instanz in einem landkreis unter 35
infektionen pro 100000 einbilde
einwohnern liegt oder manche länder
haben dass das indikatorensystem eines
landes ein vergleichbar niedrigeres
infektionsgeschehen widerspiegelt und
dann damit ein anstieg der
infektionszahlen durch die alb
aussetzung der regelung nicht zu
erwarten ist das heißt also wir setzen
jetzt voll bei steigenden
infektionszahlen auf diejenigen die noch
nicht geimpft sind auf das testen da wir
im grunde jetzt schon ein umfassendes
impfangebot jedem bürger der
bundesrepublik deutschland oder jeder
bürgerin machen können werden wir die
kostenlosen bürger tests für alle mit
wirkung vom 11 oktober beenden das heißt
für alle diejenigen die sich impfen
lassen könnten
es ist natürlich klar wenn jemand
schwerstbehindert ist wenn jemand aus
anderen gründen nicht geimpft werden
kann dann ist das werden wir das nicht
tun und wir weisen darauf hin dass
großveranstaltungen und veranstaltungen
geschlossenen räumen feiern bars und
clubs veranstaltung mit einem besonders
hohen risiko sind und hier können
ergänzende regeln zur 3g regelung durch
einschränkende regelungen oder
situationsbezogene entscheidungen durch
die länder und kommunen vorgenommen
werden die länder haben sich nochmal zu
sportgroßveranstaltungen verständigt
dass werden
herr müller und gleich sagen wir haben
den gemeinsamen wunsch geäußert dass
die überbrückungshilfe aber wir haben
zugesagt dass die über wirkungs hilfen
verlängert werden
und das bezieht sich natürlich auch auf
die tatsache dass weitere
einschränkungen gerade auch bei
großveranstaltungen notwendig sind und
die länder bitten den bund auf den
erleichterten zugang zur kurzzeitig zum
kurzarbeitergeld zu verlängern
wir werden die arbeitsschutzverordnung
anpassen und verlängern das gilt
insbesondere für die pflicht zur
erstellung und aktualisierung
betrieblicher hygiene konzepte sowie die
test angebots verpflichtung und wir
haben dann gesagt dass wir natürlich
weiter sehr stark berücksichtigen müssen
wie sich das weitere infektionsgeschehen
entwickelt hier sind die wichtigen
indikatoren die inzidenz und die
impfquote natürlich dann auch die zahl
der schweren krankheitsverläufe sowie
die resultierende belastung des
gesundheitswesens sie alle müssen im
blick behalten werden um das
infektionsgeschehen zuvor die
kontrollieren
wir hoffen allerdings dass sich die
impfquote noch einmal deutlich steigert
vielleicht jetzt auch nach den ferien
und damit die kontrolle natürlich
automatisch viel einfacher wird als wenn
wir bei 55% folge impften stehenbleiben
wurden oder bei 62 prozent
es wäre schon sehr sehr gut wir gehen
deutlich über 70 bis 80 also deutlich
über 70 und hin zu 80 prozent was aber
im augenblick noch nicht als gesichert
angesehen werden kann
wir haben dann abschließend
geschlussfolgert aus dieser situation
beschreibung dass wir die epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite verlängern
müssen denn leider ist durch die data
variante die pandemie nicht vorbei und
leider sind wir beim bei der impfquote
auch noch nicht da wo wir hin müssen und
deshalb werden auch beschränkende
maßnahmen in zukunft notwendig seien
alles in allem war es wichtig dass wir
uns heute auf diese nächsten schritte
verständigt haben
und natürlich bleiben wir auch weiter im
kontakt um das weitere geschehen auch zu
verfolgen
der regierende bürgermeister ja ich will
gleich zu beginn betonen dass ich es gut
finde dass wir uns heute getroffen haben
und nicht erst ende august denn wir
haben zwei wichtige themen miteinander
beraten die dringlich sind und wo viele
menschen glaube ich auch darauf warten
dass wir uns positionieren und sie auch
unterstützen und das wird natürlich ganz
besonders deutlich beim ersten punkt den
wir diskutiert haben der fluthilfe es
sind hier wirklich tragische bilder die
man dort sieht und bitter wenn man sieht
wie viele menschen von einer minute auf
die andere ihre lebensgrundlage ihr
zuhause verloren haben das ist unfassbar
dass so etwas geschehen kann
und insofern war es wirklich gut das
auch zu spüren dass alle hier helfen
wollen
es sind natürlich vor allen dingen auch
diejenigen die vor ort sind den
helferinnen und helfern die dort konkret
unterstützen kann man gar nicht genug
danken und darf es ja nie vergessen wir
sind immer noch bundesweit ja auch in
einer ausnahmesituation in einer
pandemie und jeder hat damit auch noch
selbst zu kämpfen
aber das ist großartig zu sehen wie viel
hilfe ist dann doch vor ort für die
menschen gibt die es im noch dringender
brauchen diese unterstützung und wir
wollten das auch natürlich mit unserer
politischen beschlussfassung ausdrücken
dass es so wie die bundeskanzlerin
gesagt hat auch als wir intern
diskutiert haben war das sehr sehr
schnell klar und völlig unstrittig dass
wir hier gemeinsam auch finanziell
unterstützen werden und gemeinsam bund
und länder wirklich auch große summen
zur verfügung stellen ja das ist eine
kraftanstrengung auch für die länder
nicht nur für den bund das ist eine
kraftanstrengung aber eine nötige und
eine unstrittig geleistete
kraftanstrengung die er auch miteinander
beschlossen wurde
also insofern glaube ich ein wichtiges
signal auch und ich will auch sagen dass
doch durch diese dramatischen bilder
auch allen noch mal ganz bewusst wurde
dass es auch jeden treffen kann sehen
welche auswirkungen die
veränderungen die klimaveränderungen
haben die naturkatastrophen sich schnell
wirklich in ein ungeahntes ausmaß
entwickeln können und dass das
tatsächlich auch jeden treffen kann
sicherlich in unterschiedlicher form
unterschiedlicher dynamik aber ist es
klar wir sind hier solidarisch und wir
wollen unterstützen
beim thema corona ist es so dass wir ja
wieder steigende zahlen sehen dass wir
sehen dass wir auch achtsam sein müssen
wie die infektionen sich entwickeln und
welche infektions dynamik es gibt das
ist richtig wir sind in einer anderen
situation als vor einem jahr
wir haben andere erkenntnisse wir haben
eine noch tiefere wissenschaftliche
begleitung wir haben andere test
kapazitäten eine andere test vielfalt
und wir haben vor allen dingen die
impfstoffe und auch den entsprechenden
im fortschritt und doch muss man ganz
klar sagen ist hier noch etwas zu tun
und zwar jenseits von einschränkenden
maßnahmen auch wir haben einen guten in
fortschritt aber die gruppe der
ungeimpften ist zu groß da gibt es
nichts drumherum zu reden und es ist
schon bitter dass auch zu sehen dass so
viele immer noch vorbehalte haben oder
angebote nicht annehmen wenn wir uns das
noch mal überlegen wie die situation vor
einem jahr war oder anfang ende 19 19
anfang 2020 wie wir händeringend darauf
gewartet haben dass dass wir endlich die
impfstoffe haben dass wir die
infrastruktur die wir aufgebaut haben
nutzen können für die impf angebote dann
kam die impfstoffe viele impfstoffe
kamen wir konnten sehr schnell helfen
wir konnten denen helfen die besonders
betroffen waren besonders hier geschützt
werden mussten die älteren die jüngeren
haben gewartet
wir haben dann immer mehr impfstoffe
bekommen und konnten immer mehr angebote
machen und dass wir dann jetzt immer
noch bei einer impfquote von 60 und 60
prozent sind das ist gut aber das macht
deutlich dass wir auch gemeinsam noch
viel zu tun haben
an dieser stelle und ich sehe auch auf
gerade in berlin sehe ich dass wir
können uns aus der kombination von
testmöglichkeiten und imf angeboten
können wir uns wieder viel zutrauen
wir können uns theater gehen wir können
ins kino gehen wir können zu
sportveranstaltungen gehen alles das was
wir über monate vermisst haben aber wir
müssen uns das doch erhalten und wir
müssen es uns vor allen dingen durch ein
schnelleres impfen erhalten durch eine
deutlich höhere quote impfen impfen es
nach wie vor das gebot der stunde
und wir sehen ja auch wie die impfung
schützt wir sehen es bei den ältesten
wie sie geschützt sind durch eine sehr
hohe impfquoten und wir sehen ihn leider
auch bei den jüngeren wo wir noch ein
relativ niedrige impfquote haben wie die
instanzen nach oben gehen ich sage das
ohne vorwurf denn wir wissen auch die
jüngeren haben erst später ein
entsprechendes impfangebot bekommen
viele studierende zb kommen jetzt auch
erst wieder zurück in die stadt um sich
auf das wintersemester vorzubereiten
aber wir haben in berlin in der gruppe
der 15 bis 25 jährigen eine inzidenz die
um die 100 liegt dort wo wir eben auch
noch nicht
einen entsprechenden im fortschritt
haben und insofern ist das auch von mir
ein dringender appell die angebote die
wir haben bitte anzunehmen
wir wir haben die entsprechenden
möglichkeiten wir haben die
möglichkeiten nach denen sich andere
länder sehen und wir sollten diese
möglichkeiten auch nutzen
wir haben festgehalten heute in unserer
beschlussfassung dass wir vor allen
dingen dort wo natürlich das
infektionsgeschehen zu beobachten ist
und wo es auch schnell bedrohlich werden
kann eben in den innenräumen anders als
unter freiem himmel
dass wir dort auch wieder verpflichtend
für diejenigen die nicht geimpft oder
genesen sind entsprechende test
erfordernisse formulieren
diese tests stehen auch zur verfügung
und sie stehen die nächsten acht wochen
auch noch kostenlos zur verfügung ab dem
11 oktober werden sie kostenpflichtig
an dieser stelle auch sagen dass ich es
richtig finde dass wir diesen schritt
gehen
ich weiß dass es da auch über
widerspruch gibt und dass einige auch
sagen das ist doch etwas was dauerhaft
kostenfrei angeboten werden muss ich
sage an der stelle aber auch man kann
all diese erfordernisse testen
kostenpflichtige test und gehen durch
eine impfung kann man sie umgehen
wer dieses angebot nicht annimmt kann
nicht dauerhaft damit rechnen dass die
solidargemeinschaft ihm das finanziert
dass er solche angebote nicht annimmt
und das muss man immer wieder zu ende
denken wenn er diese angebote nicht
annimmt gefährdet er gefährdet sich und
nach wie vor auch andere
wer also diesen weg warum auch immer
wählt muss dann eben auch damit rechnen
dass er die entsprechenden tests auch
bezahlen muss also ich glaube dass das
heute schon sehr wichtig war noch einmal
deutlich zu machen dass wir dieses
infektionsgeschehen dass wir in unserem
land sehen im auge haben dass wir darauf
reagieren dass wir darauf besonnen und
angemessen reagieren mit entsprechenden
maßnahmen um noch mehr menschen
einerseits zu schützen und andererseits
aber auch entsprechende angebote machen
zu können
bei den sportveranstaltungen ist es so
die bundeskanzlerin hat das gerade
angesprochen dass wir auch da sehen dass
wir uns etwas zutrauen können dass wir
großveranstaltung zu lassen können aber
auch nicht in jeder form weil wir eben
noch nicht komplett über den berg sind
so schön auf die fortschritte sind in
der pandemie bekämpfung wir haben einen
beschluss der chefs der staats und
senatskanzleien aufgegriffen und haben
noch 'mal jetzt auch als mpk
festgehalten dass
sportgroßveranstaltungen oberhalb einer
absoluten zahl von 5000 zuschauern im
zugelassen werden in einer auslastung
von maximal 50 prozent in den stadien in
den arien aber eben auch mit einer
gedeckelten mit einer höchste
zuschauerzahl von 25.000 das macht auch
deutlich ja großveranstaltungen sind
aber mit regeln mit entsprechender
abständen die dann auch berücksichtigt
werden können bei diesen
großveranstaltungen und wir wissen eben
auch das jeden satz von der veranstalter
jenseits der veranstaltung selbst vor
und nach der veranstaltung wir eben auch
so weit es geht vermeiden wollen und
vermeiden können dass es zu großen
ansammlungen kommt wo auch wieder neue
gefährdungssituation entstehen also
unter dem strich noch einmal wie ich
finde eine sehr wichtige
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin auch zum richtigen
zeitpunkt denn wir können jetzt
gemeinsam noch darauf reagieren wie das
infektionsgeschehen ist ihr können jetzt
gemeinsam auch die grundlagen dafür
legen dass wir auch im herbst und im
winter gut durch diese zeit kommen dass
wir mit einer noch höheren impfquote
noch mehr menschen und uns selbst
natürlich auch schützen aber vor allen
dingen auch die zurückgewonnene freiheit
der letzten monate die wir uns wieder
zurückerobern konnten durch besonders
verhalten dass wir die auch im herbst
und winter absichern können herr
minister sie damit
frau bundeskanzlerin der mütter die
vierte werde ich schleicht sich richtig
heran
das ist ein bisschen die trügerische
ruhe die mehrzahl der menschen denkt
dass die inzidenz uneinig ganz niedrig
sind es ist bei den meisten auch noch
sommerurlaub aber klar ist diese viertel
welle kommt und zwar ganz sicher im
herbst wir sind gut beim impfen aber
lange nicht so gut wie es sein muss die
bisherigen impfquoten reichen einfach
nicht aus um sorglos zu sein
wir bekommen die gefahr einer pandemie
der ungeimpften und das sind übrigens
die inzidenz deutlich höher wenn man das
einfach mal die bundesgrenze es wird
einfach ausrechnet und ist die zahl
derer die um geimpft sind haben wir
heute deutlich höhere instanzen als die
gesamtzahl des vermuten lässt wir
kriegen immer mehr fälle von longo wird
hier kriegen immer mehr belastungen
junger menschen die sich langfristig
aufs leben auswirken können und die
wahrheit ist wenn nicht ausreichend
geimpfte besteht immer die gefahr von
mutationen weltweit aber auch bei uns so
und so verhindern dass wir nicht in eine
endlosschleife kommen
das ist ja das eigentlich was alle so
beschwert wir können mit zwei kleinen
tipps die der staat umsonst zur
verfügung stellt oder die umsonst
gestellt wird können wir aus dieser
endlosschleife rauskommen
bislang gelingt ist aber nicht deswegen
ist die kernfrage wie ehrlich uns wir
uns dieser situation stellen
die heutige mpk war ein wichtiger
zwischenschritt aber es war noch nicht
der abschließende entwurf
ich glaube nicht dass die halbzeit der
halbzeit wert unserer beschlüsse den
ganzen winter überdauern wird da wird
sich sicherlich noch eine menge ergeben
und das heißt auch völlig unabhängig vom
wahlkampf den corona interessiert sich
nicht was im wahlkampf stattfindet und
nicht deswegen muss man heute auch
beschlüsse fassen
der wichtigste übrigens ist die
gemeinsame auffassung dass sich die
epidemiologische lage verlängern muss
denn ohne einen solchen beschluss manche
fordern einen freedom day ein freedom
day wird überhaupt nichts bringen im
gegenteil der führt zur wehrlosigkeit
der führt zu wehrlosigkeit wir hätten
keine chance mehr zu reagieren und zu
steuern
darum ist die verlängerung dieser lage
zunächst war ein entscheidendes moment
zweitens wir sagen im grunde genommen 3g
aber auch nicht endlos 3g bedeutet ja
geimpft gewesen und getestet wir wissen
dass sich die impfzahlen verbessern
müssen
wir wollen keine impfpflicht jeder
entscheidet selbst ob er sich impfen
lassen will oder nicht aber jeder in
einem freiheitlichen staat trägt dafür
auch die verantwortung der die sich
impfen lässt reck die verantwortung der
sich aber nicht impfen lässt und auch
bewusst nein sagt dazu trägt auch die
verantwortung was heißt es zum einen
trägt er die verantwortung jetzt muss
mehr getestet werden ich finde es
richtig und das muss man sagen geht auch
auf initiative der bundeskanzlerin sehr
stark zurück dann auch mal ein grenzwert
zu definieren mit den 35
das meer getestet werden muss ja für
einige bedeutet es auch früher zu testen
als bisher nie werte waren aber das ist
notwendig um eine dämpfende wirkung zu
haben also mit mehr getestet
es müssen sich wieder viele landkreise
in kommunen und die bürger wenn sie den
zugang dazu haben wollen wieder auf mehr
testen einstellen und das ist auch die
frage der eigenen verantwortung
man muss sich darauf einstellen dass
diese tests auf dauer eben nicht
kostenlos ist das unfair oder gerecht es
ist natürlich gerecht denn wenn man sich
bewusst entscheidet sich und anderen den
schutz
noch zu überlegen oder zu distanzieren
dann kann nicht der steuerzahler auf
dauer unmengen tests bezahlen das ist
nicht fair
also 3g bleibt aber mit mehr testen und
auf dauer nicht mit kosten lassen
die wahrheit ist dabei auch das gilt
insbesondere für den herbst wer keinen
lockdown will und dann locker und wird
es auch nicht mehr geben
doch dann dazu nicht mehr geben auf
keinen fall für zwei games
warum weil es verfassungsrechtlich gar
nicht vertretbar ist jetzt auch
beschlussfassung schon von bund und
ländern dem ihr nämlich sagen das team
zweimal geimpft sind
dass die ausgenommen sind von kontakte
schwenk und ähnlichem mehr
letztlich muss es klar sein wenn wir im
fun reize setzen wollen dann geht es
nicht nur über die finanzielle frage
sondern da geht es auch um die
verfassungsrechtliche entscheidende
frage wen werden rechte vorenthalten wir
nicht es gab die letzten tage auch so
eine debatte müssen wir uns mehr um die
kümmern die nicht geimpft sind das ist
der eine aspekt das verstehe ich an
respektiere sie aber wir müssen noch die
frage stellen was ist mit denen die
schon zweifach geimpft sind und den
maximalen schutz auf staat für sich und
für die gesellschaft erfüllt die
verfassungsrechtler seien eindeutig es
ist auf dauer nicht möglich ihnen die
rechte vorzunehmen also müssen ihnen die
rechte zugestanden wird was bedeutet ist
es muss klar sein es muss stück für
stück zu überlegt werden dass bei auch
höchstzahlen die gemacht werden auf
dauer die nichtanrechnung von gamestar
erfolg kann von folge
wir werden auch nicht verbieten übrigens
man sollte darüber ausgetauscht wenn
private veranstalter sagen bewusst
entscheiden zugang bei mir nur über 2g
gibt es keine handhabe des staates dies
zu verbieten
und ich bin relativ sicher es wird
irgendwann auch eine debatte darüber
geben ob es die zugänge zu bestimmten
bereichen nicht nur mit 3g gibt sondern
irgendwann zweig je länger und je
weniger geringer je länger es läuft und
die geringere zahlen bleiben umso näher
rückt man darüber muss sich jeder noch
mal selber den impuls setzen überlegen
ob es nicht der richtige weg ist sich
impfen zu lassen es impfen ist wirklich
eine der leichtesten möglichkeiten für
sich und andere freiheit und eine
größere form von sorglosigkeit
zurückzubekommen
unser normales leben kommt zurück durch
das impfen wer das impfen ausschlägt
läuft gefahr dass auf dauer dieses ganze
hin und her und dieses ganze theater mit
testen maske und allen endlos rahmen
wird also der wirklich ein
freiheitsliebender mensch ist dem noch
mal die empfehlung sich das einfach mal
zu überlegen und nach diesen millionen
impfungen deutschlands komme gesamt gibt
es ausführliche berichte über
nebenwirkungen über im reize und die es
gegeben hat und auf allergische reaktion
alles ist dokumentiert das kann man
einsehen
die relation und die sorgen die dahinter
stehen sind viel geringer als die
möglichkeiten die bestehen also wir
werden auf dauer der debatte über 2g
sicherlich nicht verstehen können noch
zwei punkte
das eines wenn man am rande über schule
gesprochen alle bundesländer sind sich
einig dass ihre müller glaube ich auch
alle noch mal dokumentiert alle wollen
präsenzunterricht auf jeden fall haben
alle werden mit masken mit c4 testen
operieren der schülerausweis wird im
grunde genommen auch übrigens ein test
zertifikat werden weil nämlich mit dem
schülerausweis man de facto nachweis
dass man mehrfach geimpft ist mehrfach
getestet ist das führt dann auch tat so
dass man für alle anderen zugänge damit
automatisch die möglichkeit hat und was
ganz wichtig ist es gilt nicht die
gleichen quarantäne regeln bei auch
mittlerweile vielen kämpften schülern
wir setzen es überall fort alle
bundesländer bemühen sich auch angebote
für das impfen der schüler zu machen
beim fußball geht es nur für bayern wir
werden jetzt nach den erfahrungen die
mir werden
wir haben es in der tat ins land gewesen
dass die fußball europameisterschaft
bronze mit sehr guten ergebnissen des
übertragenden deswegen kann man auch
sagen wir gewinnen jetzt wir waren etwas
zurückhalten will er wir werden die zahl
der maximalen ins ausschüttung auf
bundesebene genauso machen wie alle
anderen bundesländer
das ist dann unsere
fußballvereine letzter satz wir haben
heute einiges beschlossen
aber ich glaube das wird wie gesagt
nicht das letzte sein
wir werden das ganze wiedervorlage
bringen weil wir die debatte uns nicht
entziehen können und ich hoffe sehr dass
wir jetzt gerade im september ich weiß
das ist wahlkampf und jeder versuchte
seine speziellen noch mal punkte zu
machen aber corona erwartet von uns
allen und erfordert von uns allen noch
einmal auch daran zu denken nicht nur
was bis zum 26
september wird sondern den gesamten
herbst hinein wenn wir in dieser zeit
falsche entscheidungen treffen und dann
möglicherweise nach der bundestagswahl
nicht so handlungsfähig sind wie wir uns
das vorstellen können dann holt uns das
im winter alles wieder ein drum und es
war auch der ansatz glaube ich heute
idee warum so ein bisschen debatte gehen
hat und es pflichten lieber vorher und
lieber dämpfen und präventiv als wieder
hinter die lage daher laufen und dann am
ende wieder einsammeln müssen mit großen
schäden für alle danke wir kommen zu
ihren fragen und ich bitte sie mit
rücksicht auf ihre kollegen die auch
dran kommen wollen bitte nur eine frage
stellen frau dunst von rmd macht den
anfang
frau bundeskanzlerin wie schätzen sie
die gefahr ein bis wann muss welche
impfquote bestehen dass es nicht zu
dieser endlosschleife kommt die herr
söder angesprochen hat und herr söder
wie wollen sie das problem in ihrer
eigenen regierung mit ihrem
stellvertreter lösen
der große skeptiker ist wird dann für
ihn vielleicht mal einen lock down für
ungeimpfte gelten
naja ich kann mich hier auch nur auf die
aussage der fachleute beziehen die das
ja auch modellieren ideal und wichtig
wäre eine impfquote von 90 prozent der
über 60-jährigen wir sind jetzt bei 80
prozent aber 90 prozent wäre schon
sehr sehr wünschenswert und eine
impfquote von 80 85 prozent der über
zwölfjährigen was dann praktisch naim
quote von 65 75 prozent 70 75 prozent
der gesamtbevölkerung entspreche
also wir brauchen hier noch deutliche
steigerung wir sind jetzt bei 62 5
prozent einmal im punkt darauf sieht man
ja wie viele menschen bereit sind sich
zu impfen
denn wer der erstimpfung gemacht hat
wird auch eine zweitimpfung machen
da ist es also eine frage der zeit war
selbst herr müller skeptisch aber die
allermeisten glaube ich wäre eine
zweitimpfung machen und deshalb wäre es
also schon sehr erfreulich wenn wir
nochmal 15 und 20 prozent dazu bekommen
das ist das woran wir arbeiten
erforderlich wir können ja immer wieder
nur sagen dass dann ein sehr viel
besserer schutz bestehen würde
gegenüber der erforderlichkeit noch mehr
maßnahmen zu ergreifen dass muss man
ganz einfach sagen wer am keine
impfpflicht
sondern wir können das jetzt nur immer
wieder deutlich machen und gleichzeitig
einfach auch jeden der sich hat impfen
lassen und das sind ja immerhin schon
55,1 prozent der bevölkerung bitten am
besten noch mal zu gucken ob man noch
jemand werben kann
der ist genauso macht zu der frage die
bayerische staatsregierung arbeitet er
immer mit einheitlichen beschlüssen es
war bislang so das wird auch so weiter
gehen und nach den leichten irritationen
der letzten tage hat sich das aber
wieder sehr beruhigt ich habe auch die
rückmeldung vor ort der landrätin auch
des koalitionspartners ist alles wie
kriegen es gut hin
herr fried süddeutsche zeitung
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben darauf
hingewiesen dass die inzidenz zahlen
inzwischen anderes korrelieren wegen der
zahlen der geimpften gibt es ja schon
eine längere diskussion darüber welche
werte da künftig gelten sollen offenbar
hat es darüber heute keine einigkeit
gegeben herr müller hat heute morgen
schon
ich glaube im morgenmagazin kritisiert
dass das gesundheitsministerium da
keinen konkreten vorschlag vorgelegt hat
wie soll das weitergehen wann wird es da
neue richtwerte und orientierungswerte
geben also ich glaube wir haben ja uns
auch in der vergangenheit immer nach den
gegebenheiten gerichtet wir haben auch
mit eine bundesweite instanz von 23,5
glaube ich am heutigen tag und wir haben
der impfquote wie ich sie genannt habe
wie das vielleicht in vier oder sechs
wochen ist gerade was die impfquote
anbelangt kann ich nicht sagen
das heißt und in abhängigkeit von der
impfquote können wir uns bestimmte
intention und abgeleitet davon wieder
bestimmte belastungen des
gesundheitssystems müssen wir beobachten
und ich halte es zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
für sehr schwierig für was wäre bei
welcher impfquote dann welche instanz
und in der folge wahrscheinlich welche
haus privatisierungs rate und intensiv
rate wir müssen diese faktoren und alle
anschauen und das hängt jetzt auch
richtigerweise nicht mehr davon ab wie
ist die gesamt incident sondern herr
müller hat das gesagt wie gesamt instanz
bei den über 60 jährigen ist man auch
mit noch sehr sehr niedrig und wenn
davon
von dieser gruppe 80 prozent geimpft
sind dann muss man im grunde die
institute mal fünf nehmen denn ein
fünftel ist nicht geimpft wenn aber die
inzidenz bei den 20 bis 29 jährigen
dramatisch steigt dann werden auch die
natürlich krankenhausaufenthalte und
ähnliches haben das heißt also ich habe
sehr sehr viele variablen die von der
impfquote abhängig und dazu heute jetzt
eine aussage zu machen was machen wir
denn da haben wir erst mal noch eine
andere diskussion wie gehen wir mit den
geimpften um und alles was wir bisher
gemacht haben
das kontakt beschränkungen bei der
bundes notenbanken bei feiern waren da
sind die geimpften immer ausgenommen
worden und deshalb hängt es dann sehr
sehr davon ab wieviel nicht geimpfte wir
haben wenn wir uns wieder maßnahmen
überlegen und deshalb ist das heute der
richtige tag gewesen erst einmal zu
beschließen dass wir mit den jetzigen
werten mit 3g also getestet geimpft
genesen versuchen die dynamik
desinfektions geschehens zu verlangsamen
und dann in der zwischenzeit alle
maßnahmen und möglichkeiten nutzen noch
mehr menschen vom impfen zu überzeugen
und dann kommen wir die diskussion
müssen wir sie vielleicht einen kleinen
satz ergänzen das ist wirklich die
kniffligste frage von allem weil auf der
einen seite ist klar ohne incidents geht
es nicht weil die inzidenz ist einfach
die zahl der infektionen das völlig klar
ohne die inzidenz kann keiner damit
rausreden wir müssen ja sehen wie viele
infizieren sich aber wie man das in die
richtige relation bringen wir welche
folgen dann dadurch ableitet hat man
heute in der mpk gesehen waren alle will
ich darüber zu diskutieren aber wenn man
ganz ehrlich sind so richtiges konzept
wie man das macht und auch verständlich
kommunikativ ist noch nicht da deswegen
ist jetzt glaube ich mal sinnvoll dass
die diskussion wird weitergeführt in
einem fachgremien aber natürlich spielt
die hospitalisierung rolle können heute
nicht 50 als gleiche maßstab nehmen oder
hunderte sind gibt es auch keine
notbremse mehr wundert also man kann es
als habe ja schon auswirkungen weil man
keine notbremse macht die amerikaner
festhalten bei einem exorbitant
ansteigenden verhalten oder bei
bestimmten veranstaltungen müssen
hygiene konzepte vorlegen und kein super
spacer event daraus zu machen
aber im grunde genommen ist es eine
knifflige frage wo es noch keine
endgültige antwort gibt und mein
eindruck ist da diskutieren sowohl der
bund also der bundesgesundheitsminister
rk ii landesgesundheitsminister noch
nicht warum aber es ist noch keine kann
man es wirklich sagen keine glücksformel
gefunden die das alles schon ins ins ins
ins logik das ist gar nicht so ein
bisschen das problem
und darum ja alles sind eigentlich
bereiten oder zu leben bund die länder
aber ganz ehrlich so eine richtige
lösung hat man noch nichts und da muss
man auch daran arbeiten und vielleicht
geht es auch vielleicht geht es aber
auch nicht das muss man einfach sagen so
wie die bundeskanzlerin
wobei eine grundlage oder ich kann man
das ja auch sagen dass es was ist seine
eigenen ländern ergibt dieser corona
ampel dieser bahn dieses warnsystem was
sich ja schon aus mehreren faktoren
zusammensetzt also wir fangen nicht bei
null an
herr söder hat recht das ist nicht eins
zu eins übertragbar und es noch nicht
die formel für alle und für alle
situationen die wir berücksichtigen
wollen aber dass das heute auch noch mal
betont worden dass das ja auch für die
gesundheitsminister in den weiteren
beratungen und dann für uns eine
grundlage sein kann wie man mit mehreren
faktoren
doch ein gutes gefühl dafür bekommt was
entwickelt sich vor ort bin eine
inzidenz hochgeht was hat das für
auswirkungen auf die hospitalisierung
dann wiederum auch bei den schwerst
erkrankten an der intensivstation
da gibt es ja inzwischen doch schon
erfahrungen und auch ein gefühl dafür
was man berücksichtigen muss und gewicht
und wie man gewichten muss und das kann
wie gesagt auch eine grundlage für die
weiteren beratungen seien
es ist natürlich so wir haben jetzt wir
sind runter gewesen bis oft glaube ich
drei nach ungefähr 350 intensivbetten
und man sieht jetzt schon mit dem
anstieg der inzidenz eine ganz leichte
aber wirklich ganz leichte steigerung
der intensiv belegung wir haben ja
inzwischen leider erfahrungen wo die
belastungsgrenzen unseres
gesundheitssystems liegen das haben wir
ja erlebt mit fünf bis sechstausend
belegungen der intensivbetten waren wir
an einem sehr sehr an einem punkt wo die
intensivmediziner ja deutlich gemacht
haben dass das jetzt so nicht weitergeht
was wir aber diesmal verhindern wollen
und deshalb wer die impfquote so wichtig
dass wir wieder überhaupt an so einem
punkt kommen denn die maßnahmen die wir
damals ergreifen wollen die wollen wir
ja nicht wieder ergreifen
das heißt wir müssen versuchen mit
leichten maßnahmen zu reagieren um so
ganz dramatische maßnahmen möglichst zu
verhindern und deshalb heute diese
entscheidung für die ich sehr froh bin
dass eben spätestens bei 35 incidence
dann in allen in veranstaltungen
getestet wird und dann mal schauen ob
man damit das infektionsgeschehen besser
in den griff bekommt das heißt aber auch
dass für alle großveranstaltung bars
clubs und so weiter sicherlich noch
weitere maßnahmen durch die länder was
ja auch der fall ist immer wieder
ergriffen werden ist frau früh auf er
sollte sie sprachen von einem heutigen
zwischenergebnis wir genau sehen dann
ihrer vorstellung nach aus dann die
maßnahmen konkrete maßnahmen beim
endergebnis aus und frau merkel und herr
müller würden sie das ähnlich bewerten
diese einschätzung eines heutigen
zwischenergebnisses aus meiner sicht
würde ich sagen wir haben jetzt heute
zusätzliche maßnahmen ergriffen und das
ist die testpflicht für innenräume ab
incidents 35 und jetzt wissen wir ja
noch nicht wie sich das auswirkt auf die
weitere entwicklung wenn es sich gut aus
wirkt und gleichzeitig die leute die aus
dem urlaub kommen sagen jetzt lassen wir
uns doch impfen
dann wird unser problem deutlich kleiner
sein als wenn wir weiter eine stagnation
beim impfen haben und die sonstigen
kontakte so relevant sind dass das das
sozusagen die festlich in den
innenräumen nicht das gewünschte
ergebnis bringt und ich finde dass wir
heute wir können einfach weil wir diese
entwicklung nicht wissen wir werben fürs
impfen wir beschließen das testen und
müssen dann berücksichtigen wie sich die
weiteren faktoren entwickeln und dass
die instanz aber immer auch weil wir
jetzt seine ruhe haben mit zum beispiel
krankenhaus bewegung und belastung des
gesundheitssystems nach verfügbarkeit
der infektion was nach wie vor ein punkt
ist wir wissen immer wenn das
infektionsgeschehen zu diffus war
wenn man dann nicht mehr hinterherkam
dass das dann sehr schwierig war so sehe
ich das und deshalb wären wir nicht
verantwortlich wenn wir sagen würden
jetzt sind wir überzeugt das wird keine
weiteren beratungen bedürfen aber es
wäre jetzt auch aus meiner sicht
nicht gut dass wir gar nicht mal
abwarten wie sich unsere maßnahmen jetzt
auswirken
polen und der einen frage stehen wie
knifflig das ist eigentlich eine
wichtige frage zu definieren vigener von
der veränderten situation ins inzidenz
impfen und genesene beispielsweise und
da stehen wir schon fest dass wir da an
die grenzen stoßen
das geht dann gab es doch eine muntere
diskussion so kann man ja sagen und noch
nachlesen
das zweite ist ein bisschen sie im
wettlauf mit der zeit als er nicht so
das testnetz der neue idee werde
wir testen seit einem jahr wie die
weltmeister in deutschland also was
testen dürfen wir uns keinen vorwurf
machen da wurde vielleicht noch nicht so
früh zu spät besteller testen ist ja
fester bestandteil
die wahrheit ist dass allein ein
schnelltest das risiko nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen werden kann weil die
sicherheit dieser test nicht sowieso
testen allein ins netz das einzige was
nach menschlicher messen derzeit hilft
ist immer so deswegen sind wir dann
natürlich in einen wettlauf und das
dritte worüber ich einfach sagen muss
das wäre nicht ehrlich dass zusagen
gehören jetzt immer sehr viele proteste
von ungeimpften wir leben in der
politischen debatte eine sehr lautstark
argumentation empire respekt davor zu
sagen man will sie nicht impfen lassen
und zum teil auch was das impfen
betrifft und die argumente von
verständlichen argumenten bis hin zu
sehr überraschen den argumenten ich
freue mich jetzt mal ganz höflich und
dann nix auszulösen
aber es gibt auch immer mehr menschen
die noch stiller wenn mal lauter sagen
wieso ich bin zweimal geimpft
ich möchte jetzt meine rechte wieder
haben und das wird relativ deutlich
irgendeiner verfassungsrechtlichen
problem sein weil gerichtsentscheidung
kommen werden und sagen werden menschen
die zwar an ergänzt sind kann man nicht
ihrer rechte sozusagen berauben deswegen
glaube ich müssen uns den diskussion
stellen
da gibt es einige minister wir sehen die
sind noch zurückhaltend ein gewehr
tschentscher dann würde ich jetzt teilen
auch seine auffassung das wird uns noch
beschäftigen und es würde uns auch noch
beschäftigen
ich bin sicher im september spätestens
dann danach und das meine ich dem thema
wird man auch nicht ausfallen könnte ich
finde es in ordnung wir sind immer haben
immer auf sicht gefahren auf der sicht
fahren bedeutet auch dass man manchmal
dann hat korrigieren muss und ich glaube
dass der hinweis auf viele menschen die
sich impfen lassen wollen dass es
irgendwann auch statt
die frage der unterscheidung geben kann
bei den rechten ist einfach ehrlich und
das muss man ehrlich auch diskutiert das
ist der punkt der den ich einfach
aussprechen möchte nicht den vorwurf zu
haben ihr habt dann irgendwann einmal
nicht drüber geredet
das muss man einfach sein ich kann mit
der formulierung zwischenergebnis auch
gut leben weil es ja offensichtlich so
ist dass wir noch eine ganze strecke
zusammen gehen müssen um dann die
gewünschten erfolge der gewünschte
impfquote auch wirklich zu erreichen und
wir haben das auch in den letzten
anderthalb jahren gelernt dass auch
immer wieder etwas passieren kann dass
wir uns mit neuen virus varianten
auseinandersetzen müssen dass die ein
oder andere situation im zusammenleben
dazu führt dass es wieder neues
infektionsgeschehen gibt also insofern
gehe ich auch davon aus wir werden
dranbleiben müssen an dem thema nur wird
es noch mal betonen es gibt überhaupt
keinen grund immer nur traurig in die
gegend zu gucken
wir haben viel erreicht wir haben in den
letzten anderthalb jahren vielen
menschen das leben gerettet
durch unsere maßnahmen durch die dinge
die von vielen leuten solidarisch
mitgetragen wurden durch den fortschritt
durch die hefe in den krankenhäusern wir
haben sehr viel erreicht und jetzt
müssen wir eben nicht wie in vergangenen
monaten nur über absagen reden dass
dinge nicht stattfinden können
veranstaltungen konzerte nicht
stattfinden können doch sie können
stattfinden so ein riesenfortschritt ein
riesenerfolg und es geht jetzt genau
darum sich das zu erhalten
es gibt genau darum dass nicht durch
unbesonnen das verhalten zu riskieren
deswegen ist es nötig was die kanzlerin
sagt jetzt jetzt an dieser stelle sich
mit maßnahmen mit dingen
auseinanderzusetzen die das absichern
was wir erreicht haben
jenseits von absagen und einschränkung
niedrigschwellig ist das was wir hier im
moment miteinander verabredet haben aber
es kann ganz viel erreichen wenn es von
vielen leuten mitgetragen wird
und nochmal auch wenn manche es nicht
mehr hören können doch es geht um das
impfen
es geht genau darum es geht genau darum
auch mit dem impfen uns das was wir
erreicht haben ihm zu sichern für die
kommenden monate und ich finde da kann
man auch vor der zuversicht in den
nächsten monate
und kann darauf aufbauen was wir in den
vergangenen monaten miteinander
verabredet haben und solidarisch
umgesetzt haben wir haben es gibt einen
folgetermin deswegen aber nur noch zeit
für eine wirklich kurze frage und die
kommt von herrn fischer von dpa vielen
dank frau bundeskanzlerin herr söder hat
es eben relativ klar gesagt ein lock
down wie im letzten herbst oder winter
wird es nicht noch einmal geben der
nordrhein westfälische ministerpräsident
laschet hat sich heute im düsseldorfer
landtag ähnlich geäußert würden sie sich
dieser klaren ansage anschließen würden
sie ausschließen dass es lockdown
maßnahmen wie im letzten herbst und
winter nicht mehr geben wird dieses jahr
ja wir haben ja eben schon mehrfach
gesagt alle hände ich die frage welche
rechts beschränkungen kann ich denn für
dienste machen und das kann ich nicht
das haben wir schon bisher nicht gemacht
wird werden einschränkungen deutlich
anders aussehen wenn bei den über
60-jährigen 80 prozent doppelt geimpft
sind
auch da muss ich wieder einschränken
machen solange wir keine mutation haben
die läden impfeffekt völlig infrage
stellt nicht das bis jetzt haben wir ist
das eine sehr sehr gute nachricht aber
solange der impfstoff wirkt können wir
nicht einfach sagen ein gamestar darf
nicht sozusagen seine rechte als bürger
ausüben und damit ist jeder
beschränkende maßnahmen deutlich anders
strukturiert als das bisher ist die
geimpften müssen sich jetzt ja auch
nicht testen lassen das so und die
geimpften werden dann auch sicherlich
anders behandelt als die nicht geimpften
wenn man eine weitere steigerung des
infektionsgeschehen es hat aber wir
werden nicht zulassen dass das bleibt
das gleiche dass unser gesundheitssystem
überlastet wird
das können wir überhaupt nicht
verantworten also zu glauben wir können
jetzt den weg in die herren immunität
gehen und einfach mal jedem der gefahr
das impliziert werden es aussetzen weil
wir keinerlei beschränkung wollen dass
werden
nicht tun können sondern wir werden dann
immer wieder sagen du hast die chance
durch schimpfen rauszukommen und es gibt
ja auch eine diskussion dass jeder dann
darf mit leben muss mit den folgen wenn
er sich oder sie sich nicht eben findest
okay aber wir müssen auch an die denken
die dann in den krankenhäusern die
arbeit tun und eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems muss ausgeschlossen
werden aber die beschränkt sich daneben
im wesentlichen das ist auch ganz ganz
ganz ganz wenige ausnahmen vielleicht
nach jetzigem erkenntnisstand auf die
nicht geimpften vielen dank ja also
soweit die beschlüsse der wir haben es
gerade gehört 29 pressekonferenz des 29
treffens von bund und ländern in der
korona pandemie es wurde beschlossen was
in den nächsten wochen und monaten
gelten soll die beschlüsse genau werden
wird leicht mit nicole diekmann manchmal
zusammenfassend ich kann noch mal kurz
sagen frau merkel die bundeskanzlerin
hat zu anfang den helfern der
flugkatastrophe gedankt das ist ein
anderes thema was wir auch nochmal
gleich behandelt werden wir werden mit
dem bürgermeister von stolberg amerikas
reden über die situation bei ihm vor ort
und was er jetzt quasi braucht ob die
hilfen so in seinen augen richtig sind
aber zuerst einmal über corona wollen
wir jetzt sprechen
frau merkel hat gerade noch mal betont
wir werden nicht zulassen dass das
gesundheitssystem überlastet wird sie
hat dringend appelliert an alle
verantwortlichen quasi ja die impfquote
weiter hochzutreiben auch alle john
bereits geimpften hat sie gebeten in
ihrem freundes- und bekanntenkreis für
die impfung zu werben michael müller der
regierende bürgermeister von berlin auch
betont die gruppe der inde ungeimpften
sei zu groß er sagte ist bitter dass so
viele vorbehalte haben der sich auch
hier bei uns in den kommentaren im chat
dass es so viele menschen mit vielen
vorbehalten gibt er sagte aber auch ein
satz den ich ganz interessant fand er
sagte es gibt keinerlei gründe immer nur
traurig in die gegend zu gucken mann
hatte bereits viel erreicht und markus
söder hat dafür appelliert und auch
dafür geworben dass die verlängerung der
epidemischen notlage
notwendig sei die der bundestag in einer
sondersitzung beschließen soll so war
jetzt kommen wir mal zu den einzelnen
beschlüssen wie besprechen wir zusammen
wie meistens mit nicole diekmann in
berlin also nicole fanden wir mal vorne
an
bei der 3g regel das noch mal kurz
zusammengefasst hier gab es auch schon
eine frage ab wann gilt die kannst du
noch mal kurz erläutern was das ganze
ist und was auf uns zukommen wird
die 3g regel besagt dass nur getestete
geimpfte oder genese in innenräume zum
beispiel dürfen also ins restaurant im
hotel übernachten ins schwimmbad gehen
also sport im innenraum machen ins
krankenhaus kommen um zum beispiel
verwandte zu besuchen
zum friseur zu gehen das ist die
dreijährige die wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe ab einer inzidenz von 35
gelten soll
zeitlichen rahmen gab es da irgendwie
was hast du etwas gehört
nee ich bin mir tatsächlich auch
unsicherheit was gab die tatsächlich
fragen ab wann soll das gelten was ich
interessant fand das gab herr vorhinein
viele diskussionen ob die instanz wie
sie jetzt ja schon seit langem kennen
aufgebaut werden soll ob die auch noch
aussagekräftig ist auch hier viele
kommentare bei uns im chat die sagen das
sagt doch eigentlich gar nichts mehr aus
eben weil die menschen teilweise geimpft
sind teilweise die variante data aber
auch aggressiver ist da gab es aber
überhaupt nichts mehr das jetzt
irgendwie dieser wert angefasst werden
soll
na ja da hat man sich darum gedrückt
also man hat es schon bei angela merkel
gemerkt die als erste gesprochen hat als
sie diesen punkt streifte dass sie
dieses thema auch schnell wieder verließ
und dann auf die nachfrage eines
kollegen anschließend mussten dann
angela merkel
markus söder und auch michael müller
einräumen dass man diesen punkt heute
mehr oder weniger neue mann hat sich
darum gedrückt man hat es verschoben auf
die nächste pk oder die übernächste wir
wissen es nicht heute zumindest hat man
da keine neue lösung gefunden
das heißt es bleibt jetzt erstmal alles
beim alten
das finde ich dahingehend interessant
weil es einen urteil vom
oberverwaltungsgericht lüneburg gibt das
quasi schon gefordert hat dass die
anpassung der schwellenwerte
erforderlich sei denn schwerwiegende
grundrechtseingriffe auf basis der alten
schwellenwerte seien nur noch für kurze
zeit möglichst das heißt wir müssen uns
aber wahrscheinlich darauf vorbereiten
dass geklagt wird oder naja das ist im
moment auch so der tenor soweit ich das
beobachten konnte während der
pressekonferenz mit einem halben auge
in vielen kommentaren in den sozialen
medien
das sicherlich jetzt wieder geklagt
werden wird und ich weiß ich wieder tun
bei euch jetzt in der kommentarspalte
ist das habe ich von hier aus nicht
gesehen
man muss immer abziehen der social media
faktor aber ich habe jetzt viele leute
gesehen die darauf hoffen dass dagegen
geklagt wird so mir hat jetzt gerade ein
kleines fluges vögelchen hier in der
redaktion der zwitschert ab dem 23
august sollen wohl diese drei dg regeln
gelten also in wenigen wochen in zwei
wochen soll das dann greifen aber dann
auch wichtig ab der instanz 35 erst dann
und vorher können die landkreise
irgendwie selber schauen was sie dort
tun möchten
dann gab es ja noch das ende der
kostenlosen schnelltests fast was noch
einmal kurz zusammen bitte genau ab dem
11 august das ist ein montag werden
schnelltests nicht mehr kostenlos
angeboten griff oktober glaube ich so
bin ich hatte im august gesagt
elfter oktober ein bisschen zeit ist
noch acht wochen hat man jetzt noch zeit
um sich testen zu lassen so hat es
berlins regierender bürgermeister müller
der vorsitzender der mpk ist eben auch
noch mal formuliert ab dem 11 oktober
ist ende mit dem kostenfreien
sogenannten bürger test denn das haben
alle drei in unterschiedlicher schärfe
eben gesagt man könnte sich als
ungeimpfter der oder die das angebot
ausgeschlagen
hat obwohl er sich rein theoretisch
hätte impfen lassen können nicht mehr
auf die solidargemeinschaft verlassen
die diese tests ja finanziert genau ab
dann müssen leute diese tests selber
bezahlen wenn sie nicht geimpft sind und
noch mal sich schlicht und einfach nicht
impfen lassen wollten
diejenigen die sich nicht impfen lassen
können zum beispiel kinder für die es
noch keine allgemeine impfempfehlung
gibt oder auch schwangere für die
dasselbe gilt für die sind diese tests
weiterhin kostenlos das sogar schon die
solidargemeinschaft angesprochen über
dieses große ethische problem reden wird
gleich mit an den decks der vorsitzende
des deutschen ethikrates aber hier noch
mal kurz zu den beschlüssen die kollege
zu ganz speziellen nachfragen also
einmal die frage von david auf youtube
gehört zu den innenräumen auch der
lokale aldi der einzelhandel ist davon
aber glaube ich so nicht betroffen naja
davon ist er nicht betroffen das ist
aber wiederum noch mal ein interessanter
punkt den man vielleicht auch noch mal
sagen kann da sind alle gleich zum
beispiel beim einkaufen zum beispiel im
bus in der u bahn
da gilt für alle weiterhin masken
pflicht dann gibt es eine frage auf
youtube weiß man schon was die tests
kosten werden ich glaub da wurde gar
nichts zugesagt oder jura wurde gar
nicht so gesagt ich habe immer im kopf
so um die 11 eur 50 wird glaube ich
abgerechnet für sonst schnelltest ich
weiß nicht wie sich diese summe jetzt
zusammensetzt ob es dabei bleibt
interessant ist aber auch noch mal in
dem zusammenhang ich hab das ja eben
schon angedeutet dass hier jetzt mit
unterschiedlicher schärfe gesprochen
wurde also angela merkel die als erstes
sprach die kanzlerin die erläuterte die
beschlüsse heute nochmal die appellierte
noch einmal sehr sehr intensiv an die
bevölkerung sich impfen zu lassen
darauf folgte michael müller der du hast
es eben auch schon zitiert das wort
bitter in den mund nahm der war schon
ein bisschen emotionaler und auf ihnen
folgte dann markus söder der überhaupt
keinen hehl daraus machte dass er kein
verständnis hat für menschen die sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen und bei dem
die beschlüsse heute sicherlich nicht
weit genug gegangen sind
also söder sprach er von einer von einem
zwischenstand und dass das heute alles
nicht der weisheit letzter schluss
gewesen sei liebe leute hier im chat
übrigens wir sind ja eine sendung die
sehr gerne eure kommentare und fragen
mit aufnimmt aber wir sind da auf ein
gewisses sachliches niveau angewiesen
das ist gerade ein bisschen schwierig
muss ich sagen ich verstehe dass es für
einige sehr emotional ist aber wie immer
die bitte doch irgendwie sagt nicht zu
bleiben weil sonst macht das auch ganze
wenig spaß und wir müssen sehr lange
suchen um die frage zu finden die auch
sinn macht aber eine sache die immer
wieder im thema durchkam und wo ich
jetzt auch schon bei manchen
medienvertretern das so gelesen habe ist
die große behauptung das ist jetzt die
impfpflicht durch die hintertür was ist
da deine einschätzung als politische
korrespondentin in berlin ist das
tatsächlich eine impfpflicht durch die
hintertür
es ist auf jeden fall eine massive
erhöhung des drucks sich impfen zu
lassen michael müller war heute morgen
aus an ihrem zdf morgenmagazin und
sprach da auch von einer möglichen
weiteren eskalationsstufe als es um das
thema ende der kostenlosen tests ging er
sagte ehrlich wir reden jetzt davon dass
die kostenlosen schnelltests abgeschafft
werden
das heißt man muss dann für die
schnelltests zahlen die nächste ich sage
es nochmal eskalationsstufe während dann
mögliche pcr-test sie sind ja teurer als
die schnelltest das heißt daraus haben
auch erhaben auch er und auch markus
wieder gerade keinen hehl gemacht diese
maßnahme zu sagen wir schaffen
diese kostenlosen tests ab die ziele zum
einen tatsächlich wahrscheinlich auf die
solidarische gemeinschaft zu sagen na ja
das wird vom geld aller finanziert aus
den großen töpfen in die alle einzahlen
warum sollen die geimpften dafür zahlen
dass andere sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen aber das ist eben die nächste
stufe es ist jan zweiklang wenn man sagt
also wenn man wieder genesen ist noch
geimpft und man will ins restaurant
mattl in urlaub fahren man will ins
schwimmbad dann muss man einen test
verzeigt und dem muss man dann wiederum
bezahlen
natürlich ist es dann auch eine
rechenaufgabe zu sagen es ist mir das
wert also bleiben sie zu hause gehe ich
nirgendwo mehr hin nehme ich an einem
bedeutenden teil des öffentlichen lebens
nicht mehr teil
gehe ich mit meinen freunden im zweifel
nicht essen weil ich nicht geimpften
oder zahle ich das geld dafür oder eben
auch auf der anderen seite habe ich das
geld dafür überhaupt ob das ganze eine
pflicht oder ein zweites versprechen mit
leicht mit alina dix nicole vielen dank
bis hierhin für deine einschätzungen und
führt eine zusammenfassung und wir
gucken uns noch mal ganz kurz in einem
beitrag an was dort gerade in berlin
verkündet und beschlossen wurde
ab dem 11 oktober sind corona
schnelltests für ungeimpfte nicht mehr
kostenlos
ausgenommen sind personen die sich aus
medizinischen gründen bislang nicht
impfen lassen können beispielsweise
schwangere und kinder
außerdem müssen sich nicht geimpfte
künftig auf mehr test pflichten
einstellen wenn sie am öffentlichen
leben teilnehmen wollen so das ist die
große frage ist das ethisch vertretbar
ist das gerecht ist das solidarisch und
darüber möchte ich jetzt gerne sprechen
mit professor alina buchs dir vor dessen
des deutschen ethikrates ich begrüße sie
hallo also ich habe hier ganz viele
kommentare frau professor birgt die in
die richtung gehen
ich sage mal von ihr im städtischen
menschen die sagen wieso muss ich mit
bezahlen mit meinen steuern dass
menschen sich impfen lassen müssen oder
impfen lassen möchten
teilweise in ihren augen zu überhöhten
preisen aber ich bekomme jetzt die tests
nicht weiter bezahlt ab dem 11 oktober
das finden sie und solidarisch und
ungerecht was wäre da eine ethische
antwort aus ihren massiver sich darauf
also wenn man mit dem aspekt anfangen
dann muss man sagen das ist ein bisschen
natürlich eine milchmädchenrechnung
es ist richtig dass in die impfung auch
steuergeld geflossen ist und zwar gar
nicht wenig aber ich glaube diejenigen
die so argumentieren unterschätzen wie
teuer die tests sind wie sie sind sehr
teuer und die werden würden auch noch
sehr teuer werden
also man muss sich klar machen dass pro
person ja dann wenn man regelmäßig viele
tests nutzen würde für so ein ganz
durchschnittlichen das alltagsleben 200
euro wahrscheinlich im monat anfallen
würden eine impfung ist
initial teuer in der entwicklung aber
dann macht man sie einmal bzw zwei mal
und dann ist schluss und insgesamt ist
die impfung deswegen für die
solidargemeinschaft viel viel billiger
als weiter umfangreich und ständig diese
tests anzubieten also dieses argument
das zieht einfach von der rechnung her
nicht und ist aus meiner sicht deswegen
also wirklich auch relativ schnell und
einfach zurückzuweisen
die große frage die sich ja die ganze
zeit hier stellt in den letzten
anderthalb jahren ist wie weit darf der
staat eingreifen in die grundrechte in
die mündigkeit der bürger
ich habe hier viele kommentatoren und
kommentare kommentatoren die sich nach
wie vor gegängelt fühlen wir haben dort
schon gesprochen über die frage
impfpflicht oder impfzwang ist es dass
jetzt es wird von vielen so empfunden
die das eben nicht möchten würden sie
das als zwang oder pflicht beschreiben
was dort jetzt in berlin beschlossen
wurde durch die hintertür natürlich
immer also zwei sätze vorweg ich kann
sehr gut verstehen
diesen unmut und ich finde das sind auch
die wichtigen fragen und die werden
völlig zurecht auch kontrovers
diskutiert also das gehört in eine
gesellschaftliche debatte hinein
das vorweg es gibt eine lange lange
diskussion beim beispielsweise in der
philosophie also in der philosophischen
ethik in dem fach dass ich mit solchen
fragen auch in der rechtsphilosophie
brings dass ich damit beschäftigt was
ist eine pflicht was ist ein zwang was
ist ein anreiz und wie das immer so ist
wenn es solche langen wissenschaftlichen
debatten gibt gibt es da durchaus
unterschiedliche positionen aber das
eine was man jedenfalls sagen kann ist
dass das was jetzt beschlossen wurde
keine pflicht ist da sind sich
eigentlich alle diejenigen die zu diesen
fragen zum teil schon seit jahrzehnten
arbeiten wirklich einig auch nicht durch
die hintertür ist einfach keine pflicht
eine direkte verpflichtung offen ist die
frage und das wird berechtigt diskutiert
ob es ein zwang
durch die so genannte hintertür ist wo
ist denn der unterschied klasse das kurz
erklären was der unterschied zwischen
pflicht und zwang ist dann wenn ich in
ein restaurant möchte oder zum
fitnessstudio möchte dann habe ich die
pflicht einen test vorzuweisen würde ich
jetzt mal so aus meinen leyen deutsch
sagen ja aber eine impfpflicht
beinhaltet dass man insgesamt
sanktioniert wenn man nicht geimpft ist
unabhängig davon was man macht ich will
ja also rein ich will was weiß ich
lecker essen gehen oder auf eine
veranstaltung und nur für den zugang in
diesen spezifischen kontext brauche ich
nach dem was jetzt beschlossen wurde
einen von diesen drei möglichen zugangs
belegen dass es da gibt es alternativen
und ich muss auch nicht ins restaurant
gehen eine echte impfpflicht würde
bedeuten dass man sanktioniert wird wenn
man nicht geimpft ist und so was haben
wir tatsächlich bei der masern
dass die verbindung war da ein bisschen
schlecht
die verbindung hat gerade ein bisschen
aber sie haben die im jahr sagen die mal
die pflicht zur masernimpfung gerade
genannt genau die gibt es da jetzt
scheint es wieder besser zu sein aber
was ist denn dann ein zwang also warum
ist das in ihren augen eher ein zwang
als eine pflicht naja also warum es
keine pflicht ist aber gerade erklärt
und dann ist eben die frage ist das ein
indirekter zwang noch mal es gibt ja
alternativen also zwang da gibt es auch
eine lange diskussion verstehen die
meisten dann wenn man es richtig eng
fast in der definition als etwas dem man
nicht mehr ausweichen kann
das ist ein direkter zwang 1 1 eine
situation in der man noch alternativen
hat aber sozusagen schon ein erheblicher
druck besteht etwas bestimmtes zu machen
aber eben immer noch alternativen
vorhanden sind das wird dann oft als
indirekter zwar habe die verbindung ist
nichts also da jetzt lege ich eine
breite diskussion ja okay wir hoffen
dass die verbindung besser das gilt es
eigentlich sehr schön aber
zwischendurch hängt immer mal wieder
aber wir kennen das ja digital
entwicklungsland deutschland das ist
immer wieder passiert jetzt ist es haben
wir schon gesagt ein 2 das heißt es wird
druck ausgeübt kann man denn und das ist
jetzt die frage eigentlich soll es ja
solidarisch sein ein ethisches verhalten
soll herbeigezwungen werden im endeffekt
würde ich ja sagen also ethisch im sinne
von ich verhalte mich so dass das
anderen keinen schaden hinzufügt aber
kann man ethisches verhalten also
wirklich ethisches verhalten mit druck
überhaupt herbeiführen nochmal ich habe
nicht gesagt es ist ein zwang wenn man
mich tatsächlich wie ich das einschätzen
ich würde sagen es ist druck
ok also nochmal eine stufe darunter und
ich hab ja eben schon gesagt es gibt
sogar einige die das auch nur als ein
anreiz einschätzen aber das ist eine
wirklich kontroverse debatte meine
persönliche überzeugung ist da wird ein
gewisser druck aufgebaut aber kann man
solidarität dann mit druck überhaupt
aussieht oder es ist ein ei entdeckt
keine echte solidaritäts man sucht dann
immer noch hintertüren und wird immer
versuchen sich diesen ganzen zu
entziehen
also ich glaube dass ein großer teil der
menschen die sich nicht impfen lassen
das nicht machen weil sie strikt gegen
die impfungen sind und das glaube ich
nicht nur dass es auch ganz gut in
studien belegt dass es einen harten kern
gibt von menschen auf die kamera so viel
druck ausüben wie man will die lassen
sich nicht impfen ja da kann man mit
anreizen da kann man positiv arbeiten da
kann man sagen negativ mit druck
arbeiten das bringt alles nichts das
sind die echten im verweigerer
das sind aber um die fünf prozent
in deutschland ist in vielen vielen
studien belegt dass es nicht mehr sind
und bei den anderen gibt es ganz ganz
viele andere gründe also da muss man
natürlich auch das positive betonen viel
viel information das niedrigschwellige
impfen das aufsuchende es den leuten
einfach machen
manche sind vielleicht ein bisschen
träge manchen fällt einfach auch schwer
das im alltag umzusetzen manche denken
nicht dran sind ein bisschen nachlässig
da kann man ganz ganz viel machen mit
positiven anreizen und ich kann mir
vorstellen dass für viele diese
situation ich habe diese drei
alternativen
ein mit ordentlichen anstoß
da stellt das sehen wir in anderen
ländern die das so machen
frankreich beispielsweise macht das und
noch mehr also frankreich ist daher
deutlich knackiger die machen im
pflichten und alles mögliche aber
jedenfalls machen die auf diese art von
zugangskontrolle und das führt schon
dazu dass viele die eigentlich nichts
gegen die impfung haben beim sondern die
wie gesagt noch nicht dazu gekommen
nicht mit beschäftigt keine zeit keine
lust oder oder einfach mal denkt oder
unsicher sagen okay jetzt informiere ich
mich also doch noch mal ordentlich und
macht dann und letzter satz wenn ich das
noch sagen darf deswegen ist es aus
ethischer perspektive wirklich wichtig
wann so etwas eingeführt wird und dass
man vorher ernsthaft sagen kann also wir
hatten genug impfstoff jeder der wollte
konnte sich wirklich impfen lassen es
gab informationen es gab
informationskampagnen es gab das in
unterschiedlichen sprachen also man hat
ganz viele leute da abgeholt wo sie sind
hat michael müller der bürgermeister von
berlin ja auch schon gesagt es wird
jetzt noch acht wochen zeit geben bis
dann quasi die die tests kostenpflichtig
werden
derbe 1 kommentar von theresa den finde
ich gut es ist natürlich diskutabel
inwiefern man über seinen eigenen körper
bestimmen kann leider ist das bei
tödlichen infektionskrankheiten so eine
sache und die andere seite können wir
gerade mal zeigen wir den kommentar habe
ich ja mal blau markiert aber oben und
unten nächst ja auch wenn ihr mit lässt
viele kritische kommentare und ich lese
auch immer wieder das wort
diskriminierung tropics erfüllt jetzt
das was dort beschlossen wurde heute das
quasi menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen obwohl sie es könnten dann
von bestimmten sachen ausgeschlossen
werden wenn sie nicht einen test
vorweisen erfüllt das den tatbestand der
diskriminierung
also da muss man zwei dinge in den blick
nehmen das eine ist eine diskriminierung
ist immer eine ungerechtfertigte
ungleichbehandlung das ist sozusagen mal
so eine flotte definition davon
und das ist in diesem fall natürlich
nicht gegeben weil es nach wie vor
ziemlich klar ist dass
ungeimpfte menschen sehr viel höhere
risiken mitbringen also sehr sehr viel
mehr gefahr bedeuten für andere bei
ungeimpften scheint auch noch kleine
möglichkeiten zu geben dass sie doch das
virus weiter tragen aber das ist
natürlich bei den ungeimpften ganz
ungleich viel stärker deswegen wenn es
um die gefahrenabwehr geht ist das eine
ungleichbehandlung die einen relevanten
grund hat es der erste punkt der zweite
punkt der finne diskriminierung wichtig
ist ist nicht so einfach weil nämlich um
welche bereiche geht es wenn man
menschen ausschließt
aus den dingen die wirklich so zusagen
für eine lebensführung absolut vital
notwendig sind dann würden vermutlich
viele sagen also gerechtfertigte nicht
gerechtfertigt sachgrund nicht sachgrund
man beschränkt menschen so stark in
freiheitsrechten dass sie bestimmte
dinge die jeder mensch können muss
unbedingt nicht machen können das ist
aber zum beispiel beim rockkonzert oder
beim restaurant nicht der fall also da
gibt sicherlich auch viele debatten
deswegen wird das ebenfalls kontrovers
diskutiert aber was nicht kontrovers
diskutiert ist dass man solche dinge
nicht machen könnte beispielsweise im
öffentlichen nahverkehr den menschen
brauchen um zur arbeit zu kommen
neben natürlich auch in schulen oder
wenn man eine behörde muss oder wenn man
sozusagen wirklich zu diese lebensmittel
einkaufen also wirklich so diese ganz
zentralen dinge der lebensführung aber
ist dass mütter unter anderen seite ist
soziales miteinander nicht auch vital
für den menschen nicht meinen wir haben
gesehen wie die rate nach oben gegangen
ist von depressionskrankheiten von
menschen die sich einsam gefühlt haben
also das ist doch auch zusammen etwas
tun ist wichtig wir sind nicht nur zum
arbeiten da das ist völlig richtig
und deswegen ist das auch so ein
bisschen gemein dass das immer die
sachen sind die gerade viel spaß machen
aber das sind eben die sind sozusagen
definiert als die dinge bei denen das
nicht so stark
und rechts einschränkungen sind nichts
was ich mir ausgedacht haben oder so das
ist sozusagen so schon lange in seiner
gewissen reihe
aber man muss sie auch klar machen man
kann ja viel machen
man kann es gibt bestimmte bereiche auch
nur in einer bestimmten situation
nämlich wenn die pandemie dynamik wieder
zunehmen sollte dann braucht man eine
von diesen drei in anführungszeichen
eintrittskarten
solange die situation nicht gegeben ist
also jetzt zum beispiel unter 35 warum
das alles überhaupt nicht da ist
manchmal ganz entspannt da können alle
alles machen und dann gibt es eben auch
drei dinge und nicht nur eine
also das finde ich auch schon mal
wichtig dass man die tests wahrnimmt als
at als eine alternative zur impfung
ich persönlich würde immer für die
impfung plädieren aber wenn man das nun
mal partout nicht will hat man ja die
auswahl und das muss man trennen von der
diskussion um die kostenübernahme denn
die diskriminierungs frage die hängt
sich vor allem daran auch ob man
überhaupt den zugang hat oder nicht
und den hat man auch als ungeimpfte
jedenfalls wenn ich die beschlüsse so
wie ich das gerade gehört habe richtig
interpretiere das heißt es
zusammenfassend wenn sie diese
beschlüsse sich angucken die tests
werden kostenpflichtig es gibt diese 3g
regel ab einer inzidenz von 35 wo aber
die frage nicht beantwortet wurde ob die
tatsächlich noch taugt das ist
aufgeschoben wurden
wenn sie sich das angucken was da heute
verkündet wurde würden sie aus ethischer
sicht sagen das ist eine gerechtfertigte
und auch eine gerechte beschlusslage
also ich kann zu dieser grenze nicht
sagen das will ich ganz klar formulieren
und das ist ja tatsächlich auch offen
geblieben und ich glaube da wird viel
daran gearbeitet dass man da eine neue
kriterien ogi kriegt die komplizierter
und komplexer ist und besser die
gegenwärtige situation abbildet aber wir
haben unseren deutschen ethikrates sehr
intensiv mit der frage des umgangs mit
geimpften beschäftigt und wir haben eben
tatsächlich gesagt dass möglichst eine
gleichstellung getest geimpft genesen
ästhetisch einfach macht die ist
beibehalten worden viel komplizierter
wird das werden was herr söder so ein
bisschen angedeutet hat wenn man nämlich
auf zweig unterginge erster und zweiter
der punkt der auch ethisch relativ klar
wir haben immer gesagt als wir sehr
zurückhaltend waren damit ungleiche
behandlung für geimpfte und nicht
geimpfte weil sozusagen zu haben das war
eine situation in der war die impfung
keine wahl
man man man es gab ganz ganz viele
menschen die sich selbst wenn sie
gewollt hätten nicht hätten impfen
können und das ist ethisch ein
erheblicher unterschied ob ich mich
nicht impfen kann oder ob ich mich nicht
impfen will also da hat sich aus
ethischer perspektive tatsächlich was
verändert allerdings möchte ich auch
noch sagen man muss noch mehr dieses
aufsuchende impfen machen diese ganzen
positiven maßnahmen die man da beim
umsetzen kann
aber dann ist das tatsächlich aus
ethischer perspektive argumentierbar
jetzt habe ich einen kommentar die
möchte ich noch mal ganz kurz einfach
hervorholen weil ich das gefühl habe
entweder hast uns nicht zugehört oder du
wolltest uns nicht verstehen
beziehungsweise frau professor wird es
nicht verstehen der krypto presse
schreibt sie erklärt gerade wenn man
jemanden diskriminieren darf und dessen
wird das krank aber im gegenteil wurde
ja gerade geklärt dass es eine
diskriminierung nur dann das wenn es
eine ungerechtfertigte
ungleichbehandlung ist jetzt kann man
natürlich sagen wenn man der meinung ist
dass diese pandemie gar nicht gibt und
dass corona nicht gibt oder dass cohen
aber nicht so schlimm ist dass das dann
vielleicht tatsächlich ungerechtfertigt
ist aber dann reden wir glaube ich hier
völlig aneinander vorbei aber
diskriminierung haben sie glaube ich das
möchte ich noch einmal das wort kurz an
sie geben überhaupt nicht gerechtfertigt
und gesagt wenn man jemanden
diskriminieren darf aber ich glaube der
christen er geht auch davon aus dass wir
kurz vor der diktatur stehen also da
steht in dem kommentar drin und deswegen
glaube ich sind wir da sehr sehr
unterschiedlicher ansicht dass wir diese
fragen in dieser art und weise so offen
und stellen
und überall diskutiert als auch mal als
ich das beste beleg dafür dass wir nun
wirklich partitur extrem weit entfernt
sind und deswegen glaube ich auch dass
die interpretation von diskriminierung
vielleicht nicht diejenige ist die ich
hier gerade ein vorgestellt aber ich
habe jedenfalls nicht eine
diskriminierung das wort geredet
wasserburgs ich danke ihnen dass sie
wieder zeit für uns hatten uns jetzt
alles auseinander zu klammern und sagt
bis zum nächsten mal so und der andere
große themenkomplexe immer noch gar
nicht gesprochen hier der auch heute bei
dieser bund länder konferenz durch
gearbeitet wurde nämlich die fluthilfe
für die betroffenen gebiete in nordrhein
westfalen und rheinland pfalz es soll
geld geben viel geld geben
frau merkel die bundeskanzlerin sprach
auch von einer katastrophe von
historischem ausmaß und wir gucken dass
noch mal ganz kurz an was da heute
beschlossen wurde
weiteres thema der bund länder runde
heute der sogenannte nationale fonds
aufbauhilfe 20 21 mit ihm soll der
wiederaufbau in den hochwassergebieten
finanziert werden geeinigt haben sich
die ministerpräsidentinnen und kanzlerin
auf insgesamt 30 milliarden euro davon
übernimmt der bund zwei milliarden euro
für infrastruktur des bundes zum
beispiel autobahnen die übrigen 28
milliarden teilen sich bund und länder
je zur hälfte
bevor die gelder fließen können muss
allerdings noch der bundestag zustimmen
das könnte schon am 25 august der fall
sein bei einer sondersitzung
bleibt die frage ob der
milliardenschwere fonds auch ausreichen
wird um den wiederaufbau zu finanzieren
das ist eine gute frage die wollen wir
jetzt besprechen mit patrick haas
bürgermeister von stolberg der ort in
nordrhein westfalen bei aachen ist er
besonders vom hochwasser betroffen wie
sieht es bei ihnen derzeit außer haas ja
erstmal wunderschönen guten abend wie
sieht's bei uns aus momentan ist es so
dass wir versuchen wieder infrastruktur
herzustellen
die menschen haben ich sag mal bei ihnen
in den gebäuden sehr viel rausgerissen
wir transportieren gerade täglich noch
jede menge
von müll in die müllverbrennungsanlage
gleichzeitig versuchen wir straßen
wiederherzustellen
wir haben kindergärten für die wir
ausgleichs bauten machen müssen damit
die kinder auch wieder in den
kindergarten gehen können wir haben
schulen die wir bis zum ende der ferien
auch wieder an den start bringen müssen
und wir stehen sogar gänzlich ohne
rathaus aktuell da uns in einem
ausweichquartier also aktuell passiert
sehr sehr viel
gleichzeitig denken wir darüber nach wir
haben ja heute den beschluss gehört wie
gehen wir weiter mit dem thema
hochwasserschutz oben auch dort sind wir
sehr frühzeitig aktiv so dass wir hier
jetzt wirklich einen masterplan
erstellen wollen
um die menschen auch wieder nach
stolberg zu locken um die unternehmen
wieder nach stolberg zu locken und im
nächsten schritt wird es auch wichtig
sein diese hilfen die ja auch
geschlossen wurden und ihr demnächst
auch politisch dann so beschlossen sind
an die menschen zu bringen dass die auch
wieder sich ihre existenz ihre
unternehmen ihre gebäude aufbauen können
das dann denke ich die wichtigen themen
die wir in den nächsten tagen wochen
monaten und sicherlich auch jahren
umsetzen müssen
wie ist denn die stimmung bei ihnen vor
ort auch bei ihnen persönlich also
können die menschen noch oder macht sich
da jetzt auch eine gewisse erschöpfung
und ermüdung breit
ja gut wir können
sie können sich vorstellen wenn man als
junger bürgermeister stadt sieht die
gänzlich in der talachse unter wasser
war und komplett zerstört ist dann ist
das sicherlich emotional für mich selber
schuldig einfach aber gerade für die
menschen die ihre wohnung verloren haben
die ihre häuser verloren haben die ihr
geschäft verloren haben für die
unternehmen ist es natürlich umso
schlimmer
deshalb bin ich wirklich begeistert wie
wir hier in stolberg solidarität erleben
aber auch aus den ortschaften drum herum
wir haben aktuell noch eine ganz gute
stimmung weil man sich untereinander
hilft um die aber aufrecht zu erhalten
und ich sage mal das berühmte tal der
tränen nicht bestreiten zu müssen müssen
jetzt natürlich diese hilfen auch gut an
die menschen ausgezahlt werden damit auf
die nächsten schritte die
aufbaumaßnahmen und so weiter angehen
können dass es denke ich wichtig und da
sind wir auch den menschen schuldig
dafür kämpfen ja jeden tag und dafür
haben wir ja auch sehr
der herr scholz war hier vor ort und hat
uns damals versprochen alles was mit
geld repariert werden kann wird auch
repariert dafür sind wir sehr dankbar
und dieses versprechen nehmen wir ihnen
natürlich beim buch das wird für uns
sehr wichtig sein
haben sie schon zahlen wie viele schäden
angerichtet wurden in stolberg also kann
man das schon in die beziffern
wir können jetzt einzig und allein ich
sag mal auf die infrastruktur auf die
öffentliche straßen häuser schienen und
so weiter greifen da sind wir schon weit
über 300 millionen euro die wir
investieren müssen aber wir haben da
noch nicht die privaten schäden mit
eingerechnet wir haben dort auch noch
nicht die unternehmen die entlang der
talachse fast zerstört waren mit
eingerechnet wir haben dort auch noch
nicht die schäden die überhaupt an der
ruf am ufer gestaltet wurden mit
eingerechnet und wir müssen ja auch
darüber nachdenken wie können wir
stolberg neu entwickeln stadtentwicklung
ist ein ganz wichtiges thema was er mit
hochwasserschutz mitgedacht werden muss
auch da muss es anreize geben dass man
sich wieder in der talachse niederlässt
und da habe ich schon beim einlass
gefordert der erlass der gewerbesteuer
wäre sicherlich ein sinnvoller schritt
um auch wieder unternehmen in die
innenstadt zu locken und das wäre etwas
was man mit dem geld sicherlich sinnvoll
anstellen könnte es gibt ja auch in
solchen katastrophengebieten also auch
in den letzten jahrzehnten elbe
hochwasser zum beispiel immer wieder die
diskussion auf ob man bestimmte ja teile
des ortes oder die überschwemmt wurden
gar nicht mehr besiedelt einfach weil
die gefahr zu hoch ist dass dort wieder
so ein hochwasser auftritt gibt es diese
gedanken bei ihnen auch schon
ich finde man muss immer sehr offen
denken und auch den menschen ehrlich
gegenüber treten und meine ehrliche
meinung ist wir müssen den
hochwasserschutz bieten damit so ein
10.000 jähriges hochwasser beim nächsten
mal diesen schaden nicht mehr verursacht
dafür müssen wir modellkommune werden
dafür müssen wir aber auch sehr viele
schritte nicht nur regenrückhaltebecken
sondern auch sehr viele schritte in der
innenstadt ein thema der klima
isolierten staates müssen wir umsetzen
denn auf die jahre des hochwassers
kommen je nach dem aus der trockene
jahre und darauf müssen wir vorbereitet
sein und wenn wir alle schritte umsetzen
mit den menschen gemeinsam
dann müssen ja keinen stadtteil aufheben
sei es die innenstadt sei es aber auch
die schönen orte wie fischt und zweifall
wir uns sicherlich allen auch sehr am
herzen liegen
es gibt hier in den beschlüssen einen
punkt den fand ich ganz interessant ist
hier mal kurz raus
der wurde bei der pressekonferenz nicht
wirklich angesprochen das ist der punkt
6 dort wurde quasi dann beschlossen dass
die justizministerkonferenz darum
gebeten wird vor dem hintergrund der
aktuellen ereignisse zu prüfen ob die
bisherige bewertung einer
pflichtversicherung für elementarschäden
aktualisiert werden sollte sprich
braucht man tatsächlich eine höhere
verpflichtung dass menschen sich gegen
elementarschäden versichern was ist ihre
stellungen also ihr standpunkt dazu und
kam sie auch menschen im ort die es
tatsächlich vor dem aus stehen weil sie
nicht absolut versichert waren gegen
solche schäden
dieses problem haben wir nicht nur bei
einzelnen menschen die dort leben
sondern auch bei unternehmen und die
stellen sich gerade eine ganz andere
frage die wollen sich wieder versichern
und ist es nicht klar ob sie überhaupt
noch mal eine versicherung mit der
versicherungs höhere die sie brauchen
abschließen können und ich finde dort
müssen die versicherung natürlich in die
pflicht genommen werden dass wir auch
entlang des ufers entlang des baches
eine versicherung auch abschließen
können das ist auf jeden fall ganz ganz
wichtig und dass man auch in die lage
versetzt wird
die elementarversicherung abzuschließen
egal wo man hinzieht und das sollte ein
ergebnis seien auch nachdem wir unseren
hochwasserschutz plan umgesetzt haben
dass man klar formuliert wir haben die
vorlagen gemacht wir haben
hochwasserschutz den wir bieten aber
müssen auf der anderen seite natürlich
den menschen auf den versicherungsschutz
bieten den sie brauchen und davor haben
viel mehr menschen angst dass sie nicht
mehr eine elementarversicherung bekommen
oder es gibt sogar sehr viele die vorab
schon keine hatten und das ist natürlich
das große problem was jetzt auf uns
macht diese menschen müssen wir
natürlich auch unterstützen
das heißt der pflichtversicherung wenn
es sie tatsächlich dann geben würde
wo jeder einzahlen muss ähnlich wie eine
krankenversicherung die würde diesen
menschen dann eher helfen weil sie eben
eine versicherung dann auf jeden fall
bekommen würden auf jeden fall da
sprechen wir ja über das
solidaritätsprinzip und das ist
sicherlich in dem sinne sehr wichtig
auch für uns dass eine stadt wie
stolberg auch wieder auf wächst auch
wieder liebevoll sich gestalten kann
diese sicherheit muss man den menschen
den unternehmern auch vor ort in der
innenstadt oder ficht oder zwei fall
bieten und deshalb wäre das sicherlich
sehr hilfreich
das mindeste ist aber dass man auch
jedem eine garantie gibt eine
versicherung abschließen zu können und
das ist halt aktuell nicht der fall
die edition als interessanten kommentar
von wolfgang auf youtube der meint es
wäre billiger und sicherer meiner
meinung nach wo anders alles neu
aufzubauen und dann per gesetz
verpflichtend machen für baugelände das
ist eine risikobewertung des
grundstückes gibt es eben um solche
großen schäden vielleicht in zukunft zu
verhindern ist das etwas wo sie sagen
würden da müssen wir drüber nachdenken
oder ist das für sie völlig undenkbar
dass sie quasi stollwerck an anderer
stelle anders noch einmal aufbäumen
quasi den ort den es jetzt gibt aufgeben
also das ist für mich undenkbar stolper
er hat eine ganz lange stadthistorie ist
eine sehr alte stadt wir haben weit über
200 baudenkmäler auch das zeigt der
welche substanz in dieser stadt steht
und auch welche substanz bisher auch
noch nie von einem hochwasser so stark
betroffen war
es ist natürlich klar dass wir jetzt der
pflicht nachkommen müssen das über
hochstadt hochwasserschutz bieten auf
jeder ebene das sehe ich auch nun ich
denke dass das dann keine preisfrage ist
diese stadt kann man nämlich so wie sie
ist nicht einfach irgendwo anders wieder
neu aufbauen und das wird natürlich das
wichtigste sein dass wir diesen schutz
bieten aber dass wir die stadt irgendwo
anders aufbauen das sehe ich nicht da
müsste man ja bei jeder unwetter oder
umweltkatastrophe die ein oder andere
stadt umsiedeln und das sehe ich
verstehe gar nicht gegeben im gegenteil
wir müssen jetzt das thema
hochwasserschutz angehen das machen wir
mit den richtigen experten dafür
brauchen wir auch das geld dafür
brauchen wir auch fördermittel um das
thema anzugehen und das ist ja eher ein
thema was alle städte in den nächsten
jahren betreffen würde das thema
schwalmstadt
jede stadt wird sich mit dem thema
auch neid befassen müssen wir haben
zusätzlich noch das thema des flusses
mit dem wir leben mit dem wir jahrelang
sehr gut gelebt haben und das werden wir
auch weiterhin tun
wie zufrieden sind sie denn abschließen
der es mit den beschlüssen auch mit
dieser mit der sinnvollen soforthilfen
die angekündigt wurden auch mit diesem
großen hilfspaket was kommen soll 58
milliarden euro insgesamt 30 milliarden
vom bund 28 von den ländern
meinen sie das reicht sind sie auch
zuversichtlich dass das geld schnell
genug kommt also ich glaube die
finanziellen mittel zu überschauen bei
seiner milliarden-höhe muss man ja auch
mal ehrlicherweise sein wird dann auch
irgendwann schwierig ich glaube dass wir
dadurch dass wir sowohl olaf scholz also
armin laschet vor ort hatten und noch
viel gefordert haben auch geschafft
haben dass so viel geld überhaupt
angegangen wurde
jetzt ist natürlich die frage der
umsetzung wie bekomme ich jetzt das geld
genau an die richtigen stellen damit die
menschen wieder sich ihr leben aufbauen
können aber damit wir auch die stadt
wieder so aufbauen können oder so
entwickeln können dass seine zukunft vor
sich hat
mit den finanziellen mitteln als solches
kann man glaube ich denke ich auch an
der zügigkeit zufrieden sein
die umsetzung wird jetzt entscheiden ob
wir da richtig unterwegs sind die themen
hochwasserschutz stadtentwicklung die
themen menschen entschädigen umzusetzen
dass das wird nachher das wichtige sein
und nicht das thema der der finanziellen
hilfen als gesamtes geld das werden wir
uns dann wahrscheinlich auch in fünf
jahren noch einmal genauer angucken
müssen ob es dann gereicht hat oder ob
wir dann noch mehr brauchen
er hasst dann wünsche ich ihnen für die
nächsten tage und wochen erst mal viel
kraft viel geduld und gutes durchhalten
machen sie es gut schöne grüße nach
stolberg dankeschön und damit sage ich
euch allen vielen dank fürs zuschauen
für die fragen und kommentare wie immer
es war eine lange konferenz ist war ein
langer stream mit vielen themen vielen
wichtigen beschlüssen und vielen
kontroversen wir werden das haben wir
natürlich weiter vor treiben diese
themen werden uns noch lange
beschäftigen
weiter soll ja aber erstmal macht's gut
und tschüss